come on because of a lesbian faster
faster congratulations I'm finally
coming out now it's time for the real
work to begin so have you been dreaming
about this moment since you were little
some of you have recently discovered
that this is your calling I see we have
a gold star in the bunch recruit madam
yes ma'am
show me your hand disgusting Ellen did
not come out on national television for
you to Edward Scissorhands and innocent
vagina I bet none of you even have
u-haul on speed dial
man no man this is worse than I thought
the ladies will thank you later for this
so this is nuts at the last Tegan and
Sara concert don't question it ladies
you'll be thanking me for this later
keep the eye contact cave in yeah I
can't do it it is 9:00 p.m. on a
Saturday in West Hollywood you have a
date tonight you want to make a good
first impression what do you wear
I expected more from you
goldstar all right lady this man is
trying to hit on you what do you do yeah
but you just haven't had the right dick
yeah you see hot PG I want to come back
to my place
my girlfriend Amir looking for a third
all right ladies you've still got a lot
to learn but I think you've about
covered the basics you deserve this
oh so bitter you'll get used to it
you